he asked me to do the show
um and I was like yeah man of course
like this is huge
um but I didn't think it was going to
have the impact that it did
um
so you know I go up I do the show
apparently I murdered the show I did you
know I it was it was amazing
um and so after the show Drake pulls me
aside I'm we're crossing paths from like
he was on the balcony during my show and
we're causing paths into the green room
and he grabs me and he pulls me aside
he's like hey man I'm like yeah what's
up man he's like
you're different hey bro and I was like
sorry what
he's like you're different eh he's like
did you hear them like do you realize
what you did up there because your music
it feels new again it feels like it's
living on forever what are you doing
and I said well Drake like life happens
man you know sometimes you lose the
passion for the thing that you most
loved and he's like no no squash that
squash that Sean Desmond needs to make
music again now and um I can honestly
say Drake he changed my life that night
my life since the OVO show in July has
not been the same and for the better
um
and also you know
I have the most amazing family I have
three kids
um and an amazing wife and they got to
see that show it was the first time my
kids had seen me perform in a long time
and
I came out we came up got in the car
sorry after the show and we were driving
and my wife turned and she said to me
she's like babe I don't think you
realize what you did up there tonight
and I said really she's like
the universe wasn't on your side you
know it's been it's been tough the last
few years but the universe is on your
side you need to do this again you have
to you know I hate to say because like
you you shouldn't be looking for
people's gratification and I'm that's
not why I did it but
um to hear somebody like like him say it
and
not having to say it to me
um
was really special because it's it's
been really tough
I I stepped away in 2015 for a number of
reasons mental health reasons my wife
became ill so I had to I had to put the
one thing I loved aside uh and be just
be a dad and be a husband